in Hollywood timing can be everything
leave a hit show too early a new risk
being seen as ungrateful or disloyal but
stick around too long
and you could end up being typecast
forever these actors saw high ratings
and pursuit their biggest showbiz dreams
only to discover just how pickle the
spotlight can truly be Mischa Barton
early in her acting career Mischa Barton
was best known as the puking ghost in
The Sixth Sense
but becoming Marissa Cooper for the team
dramedy series The OC made her a
household name by the time the show's
first season started filming Barton
decided she'd had enough fun in the Sun
and ended her contract which meant her
character was killed off the show but I
was like very much ready for closure on
the character and on the series
unfortunately for Thornton she later
became a regular in box office bombs
direct-to-video films mug shots and
small TV cameos she was even voted off
Dancing with the Stars moral of the
story don't look a gift horse especially
one as cute as Captain oats in the mouth
Katherine Heigl her runners doctor Izzie
Stevens on Grey's Anatomy put Katherine
Heigl on the top of the ælis but that
was before she publicly dissed and
dismissed the series in 2008 she
withdrew herself from the year's Emmy
nominations and told the press that she
didn't deserve to be considered because
the seasons writing material was
unworthy big mistake big huge she ended
up leaving the series in season 6 and
tried her best to become a big-screen
siren with films like not tucked and 27
dresses but box office bombs like one
for the money and the ugly truth proved
that she wasn't as hot to trot as she
obviously thought even her attempts to
jump back into television failed to
impress as her 2015 show state of
affairs was canceled after just one
season she probably should have abided
by the doctor role to do no harm to her
own career
huh david caruso after he bailed on NYPD
Blue after just one season in 1994 actor
David Caruso's pursued a movie career
which might have been great if he'd
actually picked good movies instead
Caruso star status quickly faded after
he appeared in the twin 1995 bombs Jade
and the aptly named kiss of death oh
I'll give you a kiss all right a kiss
after enduring a dry spell he returned
to TV and rebounded with a starring role
in CSI Miami sherry Stringfield in the
90s one of TV's top actresses was sherry
Stringfield in 1993 she landed a role on
the critically acclaimed cop drama NYPD
Blue and she followed David Caruso's own
exit but instead of heading for the
movies Stringfield joined the hit
medical drama ER after playing dr. Susan
Lewis on the show for little over two
seasons she walked away from that show
too due to complaints about the rigorous
filming schedule leaving ER was
difficult though and she had to sign an
agreement
barring herself from working on TV for
years to get out of her contract
Stringfield found work in New York
teaching acting classes later returned
to ER for a spell and starred in a few
made-for-tv movies but she certainly
hasn't had the same high profile career
as some of the series other stars Topher
Grace after seven seasons of playing the
lead role of Eric Foreman in That 70's
Show Topher Grace stepped away from the
hit sitcom in 2005 to pursue other
options at the time it might have seemed
like a good idea because he'd scored a
few leading film roles but after he left
grace had trouble finding his footing
even though he'd snagged roles in
spider-man 3 and other films he hasn't
exactly enjoyed post 70s show fame the
way some of his other co-stars have Lisa
Bonet The Cosby Show was so popular in
the late 80s that Lisa Fontes character
Denise was given her own spin-off called
a different world which followed her on
to college the sitcom was a smash
finishing second in the
ratings in his first season behind only
The Cosby Show but in 1988 when a
surprisingly left her popular show after
becoming pregnant with her daughter zoë
Kravitz producers on the show were
willing to write her pregnancy into the
show but Bill Cosby rejected the idea
rumor has it Bonet and Cosby weren't on
the greatest terms after she starred in
the sexually explicit movie Angel Heart
and did a topless photo shoot for
interview magazines so she walked away
Bonet has only worked sporadically
afterward and has never quite been the
marquee name she once was
Michael Moriarty after then US Attorney
Janet Reno met with him and producer
Dick Wolf in an effort to limit
television violence actor Michael
Moriarty quit Lauren order in 1994
Moriarty felt that Reno's efforts were
nothing short of censorship and when his
co-stars refused to join his anti
legislation crusade he left the series
and moved to Canada in protest he has
been able to snag some work as a Canuck
including a role in courage under fire
and some made-for-tv movies but he says
the big jobs are off-limits to him now
because he's been blacklisted for
speaking out against the government Joe
Piscopo New Jersey native Joe Piscopo
joined the cast of Saturday Night Live
in 1980 and became one of its biggest
stars thanks to his uncanny celebrity
impersonations
[Applause]
by the record machine
[Music]
[Applause]
could not happen more than seven Piscopo
enjoyed major success at SNL but quit in
1984 alongside co-star Eddie Murphy who
went on to flourish in the film industry
Piscopo however had no such luck after a
major role in the cult classic Johnny
dangerously Piscopo appeared in
forgettable films such as wiseguys the
house of God and Huck and the King of
Hearts Piscopo also followed in Murphy's
footsteps by releasing a music album and
touring as a stand-up comedian but he
hardly enjoyed the same good fortune as
his former co-star he only really
returned to headlines when he stepped
into the political arena in 2016
Jeff Conaway you might remember Jeff
Conaway as the greased lightning
ringleader Kenickie in grease but he
also enjoyed success on the small screen
with taxi in what would prove to be a
sadly ironic turn Conaway played
struggling actor Bobby wheeler and left
the show in 1981 partly because he
fought his character made actors look
bad in the years after he left taxi
Conaway couldn't land a single movie
role and his fantasy TV series wizards
and warriors was cancelled after just
three episodes Conway's career went
downhill after that and the actor who
struggled with addiction died in 2011 at
the age of 60 McLean Stevenson
after playing Lieutenant Colonel Henry
Blake for two seasons McLean Stevenson
quit mash in 1975 winning a Golden Globe
and an Emmy nomination for his efforts
lured by the promise of bigger paydays
Stevenson left to pursue starring
ventures outside the show's ensemble
cast but it didn't work out so well his
next four sitcoms including the McLean
Stevenson show fizzled out and were
generally panned by critics Stevenson
later admitted he regretted leaving mash
telling the Los Angeles Times in 1991
the mistake was the I for everybody in
America loved McClane Stevenson's that
was not the case everybody loved Henry
Blake thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
oh you love to
[Music]